[Music]
popular home genetic tests could put
your family's most personal information
at risk it's estimated more than 12
million Americans have sent their DNA to
be analyzed by companies like 23andme
and ancestry DNA the data is sometimes
shared with or sold to third parties for
use in medical research both companies
say that requires users to opt in law
enforcement has used public DNA
databases to identify criminal suspects
like the alleged Golden State Killer an
editorial in today's New England Journal
of Medicine calls for more oversight it
says quote our current regulatory
approach to privacy in
direct-to-consumer genealogic testing
has permitted the creation of a Wild
West environment dr. David agus is here
David good morning morning Anthony what
are the positive and negatives of having
your DNA tested in this consumer test
wait it's fun right you look at where
your heritage are you part Neanderthal
you from Italian you from Northern
Europe you can tell all of that and
people enjoy that when you sign up you
put in your name have the option to I
mean you may find other relatives a
second a third cousin you never knew
about because you have sex ative DNA
similar to them but when you sign up the
first thing you do is you sign or you
click the Terms of Service and the
privacy agreement this is them I mean
can you imagine is there anybody in
Harry that's ever read all this stuff
yeah I tried to read it in the green
room and I was asleep by page two and so
while there is privacy and described
here it's very hard to understand or
even weed so are they selling our data
yes period so this week it was announced
that one of the companies sold their
data for 300 million dollars to a
pharmaceutical company to develop drugs
well first of all this is 23andme this
is 23 people opted in and say yes you
could use it for research you know using
it for research I'm all excited if
Harvard University is going to study and
learn about a disease but a
pharmaceutical company it's a very
different story the second part is is
that you know this is a select group of
patients who can afford to do this right
and so do we want drug development only
done on the halves and not on the whole
population so this was always the
argument with something like 23andme
let's say that died disc
that I have a disorder something that
then could then be disclosed and then
when I apply for a job that pert that
that employer says I don't want to
employ someone who has a chronic medical
condition because that will drive up my
medical cost and insurance costs it's
not the worry so Jeana genetic
non-discrimination Act said employers
with more than 15 employees and not
small ones but large ones cannot
discriminate based on genetics and so
that's not true for a life insurance
that's not true for long-term care but
it is true for employment in that regard
so in that way yours you're safe but you
know look at the privacy side the Golden
State Killer is a fantastic example what
the police did was they took DNA
evidence from the scene and they sent it
into one of these companies and then
they said who is he related to and then
they went to those relatives and they
figured out who he was yeah and so
what's amazing is is that you could send
a DNA I could take DNA from that coffee
cup and send it in and learn about Nora
and so what does that imply you know
when you want to yeah don't give me that
look
I would not do it nor trust me I have
that coffee yeah well there when you
would supply for a credit card you get
all your identity but when you send it
DNA you don't this is the Wild West dr.
David agus there's so much more to talk
about we have to cut it off there though
thank you we should note several the
testing companies including 23andme and
ancestry follow standards developed by
the future privacy forum and Industry
privacy group